[Music]
hello light oh you're the guy you're a
hell well that's not my real name
cuz I'm sure you're painfully aware of
that what are you doing here
probably yeah I just I'm leaving I
wondered if it was a difficult decision
before what was difficult decision
sparing your father's life I'm sorry
what are you talking about you must have
known it would implicate you yet you
couldn't bring yourself to do it on it I
always wondered if you had a line I
guess it fortunate for us the line you
finally decided to draw points so
clearly in your direction all the people
that make life miserable make life
dangerous
what if we can change things
his name is written and shall die
shall we begin your death god yes what
exactly can I do with this death no put
anything down and see what happens
I saw a few crimes it's gonna solve all
crime do you think that I'm crazy I
think you're not crazy enough we could
change the world
the killer is taking credit for over 400
death although we do not know how he
kills his victims we do know he's not
some of nificent force
he's a person like you or me go into the
Sun I'm just here to make sure you burn
we're not the good guys anymore
do you know what you're doing
[Applause]
I promise you you'll not super
but they want is it gone so let's give
it to them
[Music]